what's up your suckers this is an IGN
mate this is definition here I tell you
you're a little mug but what you need to
do if you're a big Uncharted fan is play
Uncharted The Lost Legacy I'm gonna go
through some of the main points of the
game I've noted down you know it's not
perfect is a DLC sort of thing that they
ended up extending into a full release
and so I'm just gonna break it down and
that you decide mate if you want to buy
it and are so a couple of problems with
the game when you're playing stealth
there's still not an option where you
can you know get someone's attention
like you have to wait for them to walk
in their Patrol which is really weird I
know in the Last of Us you could throw
bottles and bricks but you can't do that
in this and you've never been able to in
the Uncharted game so I just think it's
it's kind of weird but you do get
rewards for clearing areas in a stealth
manner and which is really good you also
get some added skills such as your
lockpick and the start of the game is
really really really good
eventually this goes into an open world
section which you can kind of see Chloe
the the protagonist is driving about and
it becomes a very dull I thought it was
just needless padding a lot of its
quests like fetch questing one of them
is absolutely ridiculous to do without a
guides and you know that there's I
didn't realize there was a secret quest
as well that I accidentally enrolled
myself on and I thought was part of the
main game and he ended up having to
collect another 13 different things and
can you imagine that when he just wanted
power through a game and they made you
go seven locations to do stuff and then
do another 13 on top of that so yeah a
lot of it is padding early on you think
you're making progress in it but they do
keep pulling the rug out from under you
and you know it's just the the typical
sort of lazy development I call it where
they've just filled it for the sake of
film now also another thing within chart
it is that's a staple of the series you
can see things that you want to jump
over like bushes and logs and stuff but
if the game doesn't want you go there
it's not going to let you go so you just
can't jump over them and you know it's
meant to be open-world and you may not
have a lot of freedom but these things
really limit you now more on the good
stuff it's definitely the best climbing
that there's ever been in uncharred and
they're one of the best climbing
sections I've ever ever played in a game
there's lots of magical moments in it
like at one point you ride an elephant
and it's just a shame that it's got all
these magic bits in but the mid-section
sold dull it's also nice that in the
game you can take selfies in pictures
and you can look at them it it sort of
is a commentary on how self-obsessed the
world has become that you can't even
play through a game now without taking a
selfie you absolutely dull idiot it's
it's sort of you know the usual you got
a gravel you're climbing up something
you grab a Ledge it crumbles away so it
can feel a bit by-the-numbers
a lot of the time I'm not gonna lie
however these set pieces I mean you can
see one going on screen now where you're
in a room filling the water and you've
got a quickly picked the lock and
they're just so well done if you thought
the mud section in uncharted 4 was good
where you were driving along and getting
pulled along and you know you kept
jumping from vehicle to vehicle it was a
right laughs it was a bit like me dad
driving home on a Saturday night you
know a bit of grand theft or hold a lad
he likes he likes it like that and he
likes to kill prostitutes so he probably
won't like this game but you know there
are other what games but I digress the
set pieces of this are really great and
the final set pieces I'm going to spoil
it now so turn it off you
if you haven't already had everything
absolutely spoiled for you but subscribe
my channel if you're gonna turn it off
before you do that you little dick but
yeah the last set piece is the train
from uncharted 2 mixed in with driving
and swinging so you're jumping from the
Train if you can't get past a carriage
that you've then got a jump into a car
that's pulling alongside you shooting at
you and it just goes from a hundred
miles an hour for the last hour of the
game and it's absolutely incredible and
I really as much as I don't like the
midsection of the game
I think 420 pounds which is what I paid
for this if you get past that midsection
then it's just a roller coaster you have
so many great stealth sections against
cos that you've never seen you know
you've never seen this in the franchise
before and you've really got a stealthy
way through things and attack when the
opportunity arises like there you can
see I just missed that car and it's very
very tense and they gets you very
enthralled in it and you've sort of got
to be strategic in your attack it's not
always gonna be easy for you you know
you will have to switch your plan is on
the fly and it keeps you engaged in
these sections and then like I said
towards the end it just ramps up so much
from what it was early on that it's hard
not to like recommend it just for this
section when I when I've completed the
game I did what I normally do you know
I've got a full time job
I'm always editing YouTube videos it's
tough work you know I mean being me and
so I thought I'm not gonna have the time
to play through this again and so I I
sold it on eBay but I was really caught
on it like you know if I did have more
time like I used to do when I was 13 I
probably wouldn't have sold this game
because that end section is so good that
it knocks the the lower quality
midsection of the game like out out of
memory you forget about it
and the fact that they've completely
polished their formula and upped it so
much to to the point where it's like
this you've never seen an action set
piece in a game like this before
and it just keeps you on your toes and I
cannot like express how how much I was
just blown away by how good it was
however like I keep saying the
midsection of the game where you're just
driving around having a goal from temple
the temple shooting people again solving
very mundane puzzles that are quite
brain teasers really just drags the game
down so unfortunately I can only at best
give it a seven and a half out of ten
which you know what I said I wasn't i GN
early on in the review but I suppose I
pretty much am i GN because I gave that
the exact same score so maybe I mean
becoming a monster now we get to pay for
reviews and other little people are my
comments for having different opinions
to me and I think Call of Duty was the
best game ever even though it was
[ __ ] terrible for the past 10 years
anyway thanks for checking out my
reviews you can also subscribe my
channel whilst you here and I'll see you
next time take care peace